how is the conference so far yeah good
sessions great let's keep it going good
afternoon everyone thank you for coming
to my session thank you for spending
this part of the afternoon with me and
of course with tensorflow and natural
language processing my name is Barbara
and I keep getting those questions if
you are not polish you don't realize
that Barbara and bash are the same name
one is abbreviation of the other I don't
mind which one you're calling me so
those are not two different names and
because I have different handlers
depending how I felt that day it might
be a little confusing so please follow
me on Twitter contact with me if you
have any questions yeah I'm happy to to
connect with you and answer them so Who
am I to talk to you about tensorflow and
natural language processing I am machine
learning strategic cloud engineer
actually recently I started leading a
team of machine learning strategic cloud
engineers in Europe so my job title is
expanding I would say with every year
and has a lot of buzzwords in it so what
do we do as strategic cloud engineers at
Google we work in professional services
and my team is focusing on machine
learning but we have teams focusing on
infrastructure app development security
data and each team is strategic cloud
engineer is working with consultants in
a tandem to provide some different
packages to our customers so in terms of
machine learning for example we provide
packages like cloud discovery ml so we
help customers to discover the use cases
in the machine learning space we have
something that we call MVM which is
short for Minimum Viable model when we
build the model for the customer machine
learning model that is solving specific
use cases we perform feasibility studies
deploys when you want to productionize
your models so this is what we do and
majority of our work is to of course
leverage the cloud for the customer
Google cloud but also to work with
tensorflow
this is the most popular technology that
we work with customer day-to-day
my background though is in software
development so I used to be a dotnet
programmer I switched the field into the
data science and machine learning is my
favorite topic that's why I've put my
career on it at the moment so you have
all of the credentials I I own all the
domains they all lead to my blog it's a
huge word because I blog like twice a
year but still you can easily connect
for that blog with me oh just tweet me
or send me the email let's let's get
started this is the plan for today just
out of curiosity I would just to like
have a feel of the audience who here
worked with machine learnings large data
science okay thanks for flow okay
machine learning in general okay
natural language processing mmm-hmm -
good okay so we have a good mix so some
of the concept of people who are experts
may be maybe too basic for you but I
will introduce them for the sake of
others who didn't get in touch with them
so the plan for today is short
introduction to natural language
processing concepts I won't be
processing natural language yet and then
I will go with two demos with two
examples I will show you how to build a
model in tensorflow for sentiment
analyzes and how to generate the text
how to teach the model train the model
to generate the text this will also be
performed with tensor flow but using
carrots which is now number one citizen
in tensorflow and then a short
introduction to how you can you
Google cloud to scale a machine learning
process and hopefully you will
understand why you have to scale it when
I show you those two examples so when we
think of natural language processing
there are plenty of tasks that you can
think of it not all of them require
machine learning not all of them require
deep learning not all of them require
tensorflow so when you think of part of
speech tagging it can be easily
performed well easily is a relative term
by some hard-coded rules you can have a
map of words and part of speech could be
the value and in some kind of a key
value storage and you can perform
tagging parts of speech in a sentence
right you don't need machine learning
for that but there are some words that
are ambiguous like the word kind what
kind can be an adverb or you can use
what kind in a sentence this is a kind
of a problem right and it's not an
adverb anymore so if you have problems
like this then you think of something
that is more smart maybe already you're
thinking about AI slosh machine learning
but there are plenty of tasks and some
of them are very complex and some of
them are solved problems for example
sentiment analyzes is quite a soft
problem kind of I will show you how easy
you can you can achieve it to quite
complex ones like how do you generate
the text that appear to be human so
let's start with more hard code problems
when you think of a sentence I walk down
the street in the heart with a smile and
a problem of parts of speech tagging as
I said you could you could use it it you
could solve it with some hard coded
rules but if you go we have the sentence
and try to build a system a machine that
will understand what this sentence mean
that's completely different task
and when you when you say that sentence
to a person the human being you probably
have some kind of a picture in your mind
and you know that a hat is probably on
the head of the person but you don't
have a specific information here and a
smile is not something you have it's
something that your mouth or in your
face is doing so understanding is
completely different concept something
that we think is purely human but let's
think of sentiment analyzes so if you
have a sentence this film doesn't care
about cleverness or any other
intelligent humor and again we apply
some rule called it hurt hard court
rules hard-coded rules and for example
that would go and seek for how many
words in that sentence were positive
versus how many are negative let's say
that's our algorithm you would say
descent this sentence sentiment is
positive but window we know it isn't
right this is an actually very bad
review a bad review and a human being
can obviously see it a machine with the
simple algorithm I just described would
have difficulties and again you're
thinking maybe maybe there should be
something smart maybe we should apply
some AI to solve this problem and don't
get me even start on subtle stuff like
sarcasm I don't recognize circus very
often when somebody tells me something
and it's not just about understanding
the sentence like it was here right it's
about understanding the context
understanding the person who is telling
you that understanding the relationship
you had with this person much much more
complex thing by the way apparently
machines still cannot do it so there's
still some human stuff left for us right
but when we think of natural language
processing I think we have when I talk
to people we have this picture in mind
for those of you who haven't watched
Blade Runner this
the scene from Blade Runner the old one
not the new one and this is one of this
one of the pictures from the scene of
replicant interrogation
so blade runners were supposed to
recognize if if this well person is a
human being or a replicant which
basically means machine and of course
there were sets of questions like how
did you feel what was your childhood etc
that those machines could do and this
replicant of the main characters of the
movie as if the if she can smoke because
this appeared more human so this natural
language answering the questions
retrieving information is something that
we pursue as human but there are much
more things that machines could do to
mimic human behavior so when we think of
passing the Turing test
I think the sci-fi movies put us in test
expectations but the reality is that we
are much more down-to-earth we are using
AI am machine learning but to the text
so first we work with text then we can
make a robot around this right so I
would say IBM Watson winning the
Jeopardy contest if you haven't heard
about this it was like the first proof
that AI is there that that there is a
machine that can understand the question
think of how many tasks it had to
perform understand the question and
understand which information it has to
search for then it has to perform the
search find this information and it has
to actually answer the question in the
proper way so kind of like generate the
answer so a lot of tasks that are we
would think purely human and at the
moment we're not using machines to win
jeopardy this was just a proof that
there is some technology that works
to do it we use this technology for
chugboats chatbots our
our chats with the machine with the
robot on the other side and there are a
lot of tasks the chat was has to do not
all of the chat BOTS perform all of them
but like in essence when you speak to
the chat bot you want to achieve a goal
you want to I don't know order pizza or
buy flight tickets right and usually
chat bots are not general purpose so you
can talk about the meaning of life they
are specified to do perform specific
tasks for example book you a flight
ticket so when you're starting a
conversation you're saying I want to
book a ticket from London to Porto right
and depart the tasks of the start but is
to retrieve this information book a
flight from where oh there isn't missing
information when when do you want this
flight so then the chat will has to come
back and asks for ask for it so I once
it asked for it I'm saying sometimes
next week next week show me the options
and the tablet has to again retrieve
this information and come back with the
options the actual booking searching for
flight is not ml and not AI this is
something that you know our systems are
already doing systems that you probably
built the retrieving information coming
back with the answers is what ml can do
so retrieving information and generating
the text and I would say those are two
main tasks that have subtasks or bugs
for different kinds of things and like
chat BOTS and Q&A are the types of
bigger tasks that contain some of them
okay so let us start with sentiment
analysis
so I've shown you the picture I've shown
you the the example how hard-coded rules
won't just work so how would you think
as human beings how do we find out if
something is good or bad review let's
say sorry feelings yes that's like very
very human thing it's very hard to
explain to the computer you know
yeah that's classifying so it's very
hard to explain to the computer this is
positive and this is negative or this is
neutral sentiment of of this text
because there is such variety of text
right the plates let's let's come back
to classifying I'm actually very very
glad you've mentioned that
so what's classification problem for
those of you who didn't work with
machine learning it is a classic machine
learning problem this is if you take 101
course anywhere you will learn about how
to do a classification problem in
classification problem in in terms of
texts would be to get examples of some
tags and classify it to some category
for example we may take some articles we
may be a publisher and we we want to
know if this text is about this articles
about politics economy maybe education
maybe art and you can see already that
this type of classifying can have
categories that can like overlap maybe
not categories but like a text can be
both about politics and economy right or
can be about education and art it can
even be about economy and art right so
depending how do you define your problem
you can have just one label for example
or several ones if we think of a
sentiment we can have positive neutral
negative or just positive and negative
depending how do we define
our problem classification problem for
text can also be for example if you have
some monitoring or like ticketing system
that's a ticketing and people can write
some free text and based on this tags
you can decide to have an algorithm that
assigns priority to it saying like this
is urgent there is a classic example
that Google did with Okada Okada is a
grocery delivery company in the UK and
very often people send emails and
they're just free texts oh I forgot to
buy a milk can you add it to my last
order and because there are so many
customers it's very hard for human
beings to go for all those emails and
prioritize this is actually something
that we have to answer right now
so they've built a system that is
classifying those emails and the urgent
ones are prioritized and go to the
person that has to take care of them
right now
right and the other ones like they can
contain feedback it can be like some
kind of like a back on a page they can
be performed later so those are
different types not exhaustive list of
course of how can we apply
classification to to text processing
what I will show you at the moment will
be reviews of the movies I am DB movies
so this is called large movie review
dataset
it's public available for anyone any of
you to use it contains movie reviews
it's already split into the training and
test so training is the data test that
we'll be training the model and tests
will be looking how this trained model
based on those example will perform on
examples it has never seen and it has
two types of rating positive and
negative and also it has like rating
like stars from 0 to 10 so you can use
either or
or both I will I will just use positive
negative there is a problem though there
is a challenge that free text is
providing if you have classical
classification problem you have features
let's say you want to classify if if
there's there was a classical data set
census and it classifies a person will
be earning more or less than 50k per
year so you can have like a gender you
can have like education level you can
see like de areia this person is living
the age of this person so those could be
features and the label would be will
they earn more or less than 50k in terms
of texts well every data point will be a
document every label will be sentiment
was positive or negative but what would
be the features and there are many
approaches on how to make features from
the text like the first problem you
could see is text can have different
lengths and have many words it can have
sentences it can be in paragraphs so you
have to find a way how to get this free
text and fit it into this fixed length
set of features so how do you do it I'll
show you one example but there are much
more of them so let's have a look of at
this example we have three documents
John likes to watch movies Mary likes to
watch movies too first went on also
likes to watch football games and third
both John and Mary like Titanic movie so
what I did was I gather all the words
from those documents I sorted them and
this is my vocabulary so at the moment
this became my set of features so every
word can we represent it as one hot
vector so also has one and zeros and has
one in second place and the rest is 0 so
if you go
this representation can be 1 0 0 0
depending which word how does it apply
to the whole document right I will show
you the encoder in a second but let's
focus let's think of how would we
represent words so this has 15 long
vectors every word is represented by the
50 long vectors but to be honest this is
not a corpus that we usually get when
work with text we have all sorts of
words how many words are in the English
dictionary a couple of dozens of
thousand right so the corpus is much
much bigger you add names to it
you have you add slang to it and it will
become even bigger so there is this
technique that is called embeddings that
is allowing you to make this those
vectors smaller and this is called
embeddings embedding is a technique or
it's set of algorithms that will give
you numerical values to first of all
change the dimension of those words
sometimes it can be can get bigger like
you can see embedded that that will
actually make the vector space bigger
but it has the point the point is it
introduces relationships between words
the relationships between vectors what
are the relationships between words so
there was this famous article and it was
showing the arithmetic that you could do
efforts if you have proper embeddings
by the way those are not real embeddings
just it's just in 2d to show you how you
can do the arithmetic so usually
embeddings have like 100 200 lengths so
basically you could say a king is to a
queen what man is to a woman you can get
this vector from from here applied to a
king and you should get the word that
represents the queen
the same you could do with verbs like
walking is to walk as swimming is to
literally if you get those vectors and
do some arithmetic I'm saying like
adding and subtracting you will get a
specific words and there are ready to
use embeddings out there you don't have
to build them but many neural networks
are building them from scratch and
making them integral parts of of neural
network itself but there are there are a
lot of resources out there for you to
use so you don't have to do it you can
just see what the research scientist has
done for you we will be using some
encoding from tensor flow hub thanks of
row hub is it half of tensor flow models
basically you have their database of
pre-trained models of models that have
been trained at some point and you can
reuse train more on your example perform
transfer learning and it has text
embeddings so if you if you are working
on some model you Pro can publish it
there it's all open source of course you
can give feedback and you can basically
use the work other people did for you so
you don't implement everything from
scratch and in the example we'll be
using NLM English dimension 129 encoder
and what it does it takes a sentence or
like a paragraph and it turns it into
128 features so basically we'll get
embeddings of the size of 128 and the
beauty of it is it's just one line you
just feed it with the sentence and it
will give you the embeddings
if you want to like just a shirt for it
if you want to see the insides it's as I
said open source so you can see it it
splits the sentences on spaces it uses
embeddings for specific words and then
it uses those specific words embedding
like in some kind of an average way to
create embeddings for the whole sentence
the beauty of this is I have no idea how
it works all I care about is does it
work do I have a proof does it work the
best thing is I have no idea how it
works right so if you ask me a question
I won't answer that but because it's a
community product you can ask the
questions directly to the authors and
they will know much better than I do and
because that's their job because there
are those community authors they will
have to answer you so my neural network
architecture if we think of it will be
input layer of those embeddings 128
input values from their sentence two
hidden layers 512 128 and the output the
outward is just one cell because it will
be either 0 or 1 basically sentiment is
either positive or negative and I will
be using estimators so I won't be
building this whole neural network from
scratch I'll just say build me a network
with two hidden layers of those sizes
with two classes and it will be
classification estimators are very high
abstract layer in tensor flow so if you
ever look at tensor flow like a year ago
half a year ago probably some 101
tutorials will go as deep as matrix
multiplication you don't have to do it
anymore
you can just use estimators and they are
just can't and you can just describe
what you want to achieve and don't go
into details because they inside are
optimized to work out those details
it's time for demo so after it published
this demo you will be able to run it for
yourself so it's on a platform called
cutter coder and if you go to bash
Aleutians combine this is my username
you will find those and you can see I'm
not even logged in so it's not like I
have special access to it you all can
run it so I will show you how we build
and classify our text the IMDB reviews
so first of all our run Python free I
will just be using Python Python
terminal so I'm importing 10 surf now
new PI operating system pandas and
tensorflow hop because I need this
encoder I was telling you about so it
will take a few seconds I also wrote
some functions and a help file that will
load the data so you don't have to do it
so let us so this is data set URL that's
when you can just get the data from this
is how I called it I will just load the
data so you can see it's a lot of data
but should be pretty quick
tonton done so it's now loading it and
we will now have a little look how today
look 50 seconds 15 seconds and so the
structure is we have a review as a free
text and we have a sentiments either 0
of or 1
I also shuffled it so it will be
different every time you're using those
using those load data function test is
exactly the same structure just the test
data won't be available during training
this is the text column so basically
what I'm doing here I'm saying take the
column review embed it using this
encoder
that's the one-liner I told you that I
could use from tensorflow hop and then
I'm building a classifier so if you can
see here I'm saying build me a
classifier and steep neural network the
engine stays from deep normative to
hidden units 1 512 128 use this feature
column this text column I will have two
classes and use this optimizer if you
don't specify optimizer it has a default
one so it can even become a little
cleaner now I have to define an input
function input function it's a different
way that tensorflow
is handling the input for either
clasificado training or predicting
things it's a little bit difficult for
people to like switch when you're
thinking of training us this is my data
trained on it here you're defining a
function that knows how to retrieve the
data it's just a little bit of the
paradigm switch but the idea is the same
this function is just a function that
know how to search the data and now I'm
training so basically I take this
classifier that I defined before and I'm
using train with this input function and
I'm using 1,000 steps so you can see
that a loss function is going well down
and up but that's normal
we just want in a long term the loss
function to be minimized and after 1000
steps we have a trend model how do we
know if our model is good we can
experiment and think like if this loss
function is below that point we can stop
at this time I just trained it for 1000
steps so let's have a look on how does
it perform I'm defining here a function
that I will use as an input function for
evaluation of my model so just to have a
look here I'm just saying you know
classify a classifier evaluate yourself
using this input function based on the
test and based on the train data and do
the same with the test data and then
print the accuracy so you can see I just
used can't estimator I didn't tune my
neural network it's basically not even a
type of neural network that you should
be using for text but it has quite a
nice first try accuracy we have the
training set it has 80% with the test
set it has 79 percent which if you are
like thinking of audacity standard it's
horrible of course but this is the first
attempt then you can tune it then you
can think of some kind of a dropout you
can think of other stuff that you could
do for this neural network but very
easily with few lines of code we have a
train system and it didn't even take
that much I'll show the next next type
and it will take much much longer
normally it takes hours to train a modem
so now we can use it to to basically
predict some examples for our purposes
so I created an a function to do it and
the RI of my reviews this was an alpha
movie and I think it was great you can
experiment with yours and let's see I'm
using a predict function here this was
an awful movie sentiment negative I
think it was great sentiment positive
because it's 80% roughly correct you
will find some some reviews that you
could put there that won't be accurate
but I think that's pretty cool because
this might be like 20 lines of code it
looks bigger because we have this narrow
tutorial thing but it's like really not
a lot of lines of code and we have our
first classifier so coming back to the
presentation let us have a look on how
we can do text generation and text
generation this is a big big big
challenge in terms of well I would say
using machine learning for real because
okay you can create something that is
generating text but how would you use it
you probably want this text generated in
some context for example when you have a
chat bot you want this to become natural
but also to provide the user with a
proper information back right so it's
not just about free text and feeling
like a human being it's also to like
make make point make sense of it make it
usable valuable for your business but
what we are going to do won't be will be
generating a Shakespeare so this is like
a beginning of a corpus that you could
download so first citizen before we
proceed any further hear me speak this
is like a big big text of Shakespeare
from Romeo and Juliet I'm guessing but
I'm not sure not an expert on
Shakespeare
and our goal is to feed an algorithm we
have this corpus and say now you go
generate me some Shakespeare I don't
know what's the practical usage of
generating Shakespeare but it is pretty
cool right so there are plenty of
challenges in that like for this poor
algorithm that has to learn first it has
to learn English right it has to learn
how to produce words in English based on
the corpus then like that words have
spaces and so maybe it has to learn
first words and spaces and punctuation
and then English fine and then it has to
like learn this play format that there
are people that are dialogues like a
person is saying then then as a colon
and then there is a line and at the end
it has to actually mimic Shakespeare
right many people write plays it has to
learn how to mimic Shakespeare so it has
a lot of things to learn so don't expect
this poor algorithm to learn as quickly
as the sentiment analyser and Sentinel
classifier and this is actually a task
that is taking context into account when
you think of this sentiment analysis or
if you are like thinking of different
words and sentences if you if you think
of them just separately you don't have
this context but when you think of text
generating you have to learn from
examples start the text and then think
what fits after this so this this is a
task when this context is very important
the algorithm has to have a concept of
memory and down to earth with maths with
neural networks it goes into predicting
the next word or even predicting the
next character which we'll be using here
and this is how recurrent neural
networks were invented again you don't
have to understand fully the details but
the idea is that the
part of the network is fed not only the
input like it was with deep neural
network but the information from
previous steps so if you have a sentence
you could think that the algorithm that
is predicting next word from the word
that you're fitting it also have
information about the past right so this
is like not a matically engineering me
introducing how you handle context and
this is what the type of input we'll be
working with
so we'll be predicting will be the
algorithm will be predicting the next
character and characters are represented
as integers so we have like I don't know
60 something maybe hundred if you think
of characters depending which encoding
that we are using so the dimension is
not very big but we'll be using
embeddings to actually increase it so
the input data will look like this we'll
have some text of some length first
citizen etc this is like the first
sentence and we cut it here and the
target data the label will be start
something starting after this we cut off
the first character but we add a
character after so this will be an input
this will be the target the label and I
already did that for you you won't be
needing to do it but it's like a huge
laborious work for any natural language
processing task to actually prepare text
in the form that is bearable by the
neural network so the architecture will
look like this we'll have those input
characters fed into this memory then
embedding layer then lsdm which is long
short term memory a type of recurrent
neural network then we'll have dancing
on network that will predict the
character after this
and we have this context idea here this
prediction will also be fed here so the
next prediction will get this character
the previous prediction and it will
predict another character based on the
context and the input and how do we
generate the text we using multinomial
distribution statistics basically what
comes that is the Klean most probable
character after the one that was fed
plus the context I will be showing you
how to do it with Kara's which is
another even more abstract layer over
tensorflow
but it's a little bit confusing because
I will be using it from tensorflow don't
think of it that much just go with it
if you use Kara's from Kara's it will
work as fine I'm using it from
tensorflow it just does this up and down
loop but it works equally well so let me
show you a demo so let's do text
generation and again I'm running Python
I'm importing tensorflow
I'm importing some other libraries and
help functions that will that I wrote to
download the data set and to prepare
this input and output all those
characters so let me set up some
variables read all of the things this
time it was much quicker and let us
print some things so you can see this
example of first citizen it's a little
bit shorter but you can see that the F
is cut off and we have a character from
the next word in that example and if you
go through those input and target values
you can see otherwise
I will now reshuffle my batch and let's
start building our model so I have I'm
saying I'm having 512 unit's 128
embeddings and let us build the model so
it may not be as visible let's go
through it like if I go to the
presentation where the architecture is
we're expecting embeddings rst m and
dance right this is exactly what you can
do in Clara's we're saying get the
sequence of embedding Alice TM dance all
you have to do is set up the dimensions
of embeddings how many eunuchs of Alice
TM and what's the output of dance output
of dance is predicted character so it
has the same dimension as how many
characters we have since I've put the
vocabulary size which is just how many
characters we have in our vocabulary
okay we have this function that will
build us the model let us build the
model and let's have a look so Karis has
this nice thing that you can see
actually yes I've built what I wanted to
build those are all the numbers or the
layers I wanted but it's not trained
anymore now we just have to train it
so we're compiling it saying this is the
method that you'll be using to to
optimize to train the model we'll be
using three epochs so it will go through
the training data three times I will set
up the check points so I will save the
model to be used later and let us train
the model so training the model is
basically model fit I'm saying which
data set how many epochs how many steps
and this is just for saving the model
just checked and code back so you can
see eta is seven minutes right and it's
just because I spiked boots small
numbers normally it requires much more
time normally it requires further epochs
to give you anything
of value like I will show you the the
examples that I got after like first
iteration we might have time to go back
and see probably not so it didn't learn
anything yet so Romeo is the text that I
put as an input text so that you have
Romeo and column go
it didn't learn anything after one
o'clock right well like at least learn
some spaces right no after one no after
some time it learned something so
actually we'll go look it even learns a
dialogue thing but it's you can still
see like it has problem of English yet
still right you can see all those words
that don't fit after optimizing I used a
little bit different lsdm RNN layer
became pretty good I mean I'm not an
expert on Shakespeare but probably if I
see something like this I would say yeah
it looks like some you know Queen
Elizabeth the time of a play right and
again like if you go back to the demo
still still learning still learning and
it's it takes quite a lot of time and
even if you go through 30 a box we have
this basic thing probably once learn
that much you need a lot of tuning you
need some kind of a drop out you need
maybe another lsdm layer to actually get
something specific and this brings me to
to the next point actually because it's
good to show sentiment analyzes and we
have small neural networks that can
learn in minutes because even this one
is small and can learn in minutes
usually those workers take hours right
if not days if not weeks if you want to
get something can actually use in
production yeah to write a talk that's
fine right even write an article but if
you really want your company to get
value from machine learning from deep
learning from tensor flow building it is
much much easier now and there are
plenty of tutorials plenty of talks
plenty of courses even avail available
for free we have open source technology
but there is there is this stopping
point and some like how do I accelerate
my learning so one one of the ways as
for example to accelerate by it by
hardware right research facilities by
GPUs thank you gamers right
we have GPUs for machine learning now
because of you guys I'm actually
thankful I'm not a gamer so if you are
great we have a Google cloud a product
called cloud machine learning engine as
a basis as a basics it provides you a
server last way of running Python so it
doesn't have to be tensorflow it can be
anything in Python but you don't have to
think of spinning up a virtual machine
anything like this and you can attach
hardware like GPUs I'm not sure about
which stage GPUs are at the moment I
don't think they are GIS yet but maybe
they are because it's changing so much
have you ever heard of TP use those are
tensor processing units that that's a
hard word developed but by Google that
is even better than GPU is much much
better like we're talking 10x but cloud
machine learning engine allows you to
attach this hardware and you don't even
have to think of a hardware in terms of
computation itself just saying I want to
use GPUs I want to used abused for
tensorflow
it allows you to paralyze your training
so tensorflow has especially if you're
using estimator has a way of
using paralyzed training and parameter
servers so basically the weights that
neural networks have can be stored in
parameter servers the workflow can be
distributed you can say I want two
masters and twenty workers in a
configuration file run my workflow and
we'll just do it and you don't have to
think how do they connect how will that
work
all you have to do is specify it in a
configuration file what's what's your
paralyzed algorithm requirements on top
of that it requires it allows you to do
hyper parameter tuning for those of you
who don't know there are plenty of like
hyper parameters and machine learning
process for example with our dense layer
how many cells are in each layer how
many layers do we have what is the
learning rate what is the dropout
probability and usually how I
classically how things are done data
scientists are building this matrix of
all possible values and try it one by
one and it's laborious and of course you
can automate it you can write scripts
but every researcher is doing it from
scratch on their own maybe they have
some libraries here you don't have to do
it you again specify it in a
configuration file I want those hyper
parameters to be tuned I want you to try
all those values and it will just do it
for you based also on a metric that is
your success metric what it can do is
also serve your model once you train it
you can serve it so writing a serving
the model from puritans of always maybe
not the most exciting task in the whole
world here once you have the model it's
being stored somewhere you go to a cloud
machine learning engine and say I want
to serve this model and it will just do
it it will create an API REST API that
you can use in your
vacation and it has two modes it can
either be an online training so it's an
instant
API rest code or if you want to like
wait for the warm up you can perform a
batch predictions so you provide it with
one API call with the batch and it will
give you the predictions your code dough
has to be a little bit rewritten just a
little bit it's just about the structure
so it has to have this structure you
have a project and then you have this
folder that is called trainer or somehow
but it indicates that it has to be this
folder and you have to do this in it dot
PI file even if you don't have anything
there it has to be there it's required
and this is where your model is being
trained but you can have also other
things like your model actually can be
defined here and your tasks can use this
model to train but the tasks can also
use some kind of a parameter so let's
say for example you want to use a
different folder at different values so
you can you can use those arguments to
be used in tasks if you want to build
your model you have to set up by but if
you're just using Google Cloud tools you
don't have to do the setup I it will be
built for you so once you run a comment
saying you know submit my job you have a
job named you you have two modes you can
either say this is the tire I want to
use and this is my package path so
basically trainer this is my module name
sorry task
and this is where my job output
monitoring etc will be stored this is
the region and those my arguments that
are specific to this file task PI are
the second way is you cross this out and
you put your configuration in your
config file in your config file you can
also define the paralyze model that you
want if it's custom and your paper
parameter tuning but the rest stays the
same there's just one command to run it
into the cloud and you don't have to
think of spinning up any VMs it's all
service so that's all we went through
natural language processing I would say
102 kind of representation we spoke
about different challenges and the
natural processing natural language
processing task and two different
challenges classification we have
sentiment analyzes and text generation
for Shakespeare as I said you will soon
be able to do it on your own and then
they told you a little bit about how you
can scale your workflow and that's all
folks if you want to talk to me just
stay in touch as I said I own all the
domains and I'm the only person in the
whole world named like me either it's
Barbara basher so stay in touch thank
you very much
[Applause]